chronicling the white-knuckle thrills of
crab fishing and the harsh speeds of the
Bering Strait Deadliest Catch has been
one of Discovery Channel's hottest shows
for more than a decade that's time
enough to bury plenty of skeletons at
sea so here's a look at some salty
behind-the-scenes tales even diehard
fans may not know about Deadliest Catch
almost deadliest with all of the carnage
left in the wake of the deadliest catch
crab boats it may be surprising to find
out that the crab seasons followed by
the show the red king crab and the
Opilio crab don't traditionally have the
highest body counts for fishermen
according to The Oregonian that to be
his honor goes to the Dungeness crab
industry with a death rate twice that of
the Bering Sea
this is apparently due to two factors
one Dungeness boats don't need a Coast
Guard safety inspection to get permitted
and two the Dungeness industry still
operates on the Derby system which
allows for inexperienced captains and
small boats to incur high risk trying to
catch as much crab as they possibly can
the Discovery Channel apparently
realized the superlative flaw in the
show's title which they've been
corrected by launching their spinoff
series Deadliest Catch dungeon Cove
which documents you guessed it that
Dungeness crab industry arrest warrant
Jake Harris son of the late captain Phil
Harris has had several reported run-ins
with the law for drug abuse and driving
while intoxicated while it seemed like
Harris was getting a handle on his
personal issues things started going
back downhill fast
first Harris was attacked in an apparent
robbery while sharing a ride home from a
casino
according to Seattle's channel 7 news
Harris was badly beaten suffering a
cracked skull and brain trauma a few
months later TMZ reported that Harris
allegedly stole a woman's car in Phoenix
and was subsequently busted by police
for possession of crystal meth and xanax
Harris then failed to show up in court
to face the charges stemming from the
arrest and as of May 12 2017 as a bench
warrant out for his arrest
according to Fox News double jeopardy in
2016 sig Hansen's estranged daughter
from his first marriage
Melissa Eckstrom opened a civil suit
claiming that her father sexually abused
her
when she was 2 years old the case is
complicated
since Hansen was exonerated at the same
charges in 1990 during a contentious
divorce and custody case in which the
judge ruled that the abuse did not occur
they´ll Hansen relinquished parental
rights to Melissa
he claims her mother has continually
attempted to extort him Hansen told The
Seattle Times this is nothing more than
an old-fashioned shakedown it's a
completely frivolous lawsuit full of
lies that my ex-wife made up to take
away my daughter and still uses to try
to extort money from me it's blackmail
pain and the uber around the same time
the abuse allegations resurfaced sig
Hansen made news again for allegedly
flipping out on an uber driver according
to the Seattle Times Hansen and his
son-in-law spat on the drivers head and
the back of the driver's seat Hansen
also allegedly kicked the outside of the
rear of the passenger side of the
vehicle causing a dent Hansen was
arrested at his home after a drunken
confrontation with Seattle PD but later
apologized in multiple tweets for his
actions I am terribly sorry for my
behavior and I'm very embarrassed by it
I owe a bunch of people apologies first
and foremost to our uber driver who was
just trying to get his home safely I
hope I can make that apology in person I
have no excuse and accept responsibility
for my actions I'm Jefferson fig and I
approve this message
no get slamming murder Deadliest Catch
has tragically covered the deaths of
multiple crew members who died working
in violent storm conditions but tragedy
has also touched the show far from the
docks of Dutch Harbor and a seemingly
random incident associate producer
Joseph McMahon was gunned down outside
his California home after he went
outside to investigate a noise according
to CBS LA and if that wasn't bizarre
enough the suspect in the shooting was
found dead in his car that same day from
what appears to be a self-inflicted
gunshot wound according to the rap
dining woes with the irregular hours and
back-breaking shifts the crews have to
deal with meal times on a crabbing
vessel are few and far between in an
interview with the Miami New Times sig
Hansen explained on the boat you don't
know when you're going to eat again they
are no specified mealtimes fishing is
what dictates your meals and what you
can eat so your diet is horrifying
you're not eating at regular times it's
hell and the one thing they're
definitely not eating crap despite being
surrounded by the eight-legged
delicacies you will never see The
Deadliest Catch fisherman sitting around
a table sucking down crab meat dubbed
and melted butter crabs are the reason
they're out there risking their lives so
it would be pretty counterproductive to
continually put a dent in their profits
by eating the catch
cameraman peril a lot of reality shows
that feature tough characters and
grueling environments generally provide
an opportunity for the production team
to leave those elements behind at the
end of their shifts on Deadliest Catch
this is not the case according to
associate producer Ryan McNeil the
two-man video crews aboard the crab
boats don't have it easy not only do
they have to endure the same weather
conditions and rough seas as the
fishermen they have to do it all without
ever leaving the boat which means
they're stuck on deck with the crew for
the entire crab run which generally
lasts three to five weeks this leads to
an inevitable camaraderie between the
fishing and film crews according to
captain Wild Bill wichrowski who told
the a/v Club
I'd say 85% of the camera guys I had
ended up being buddies we actually spend
more time with the cameramen on the boat
than we do with our own families if you
think about it you're with them 24/7 and
you don't get to see your own family
that much climate chaos environmental
factors obviously play a huge part on
Deadliest Catch raging storms colossal
waves and frigid water are all hazards
the crab boat crews face on a daily
basis but on season 13
the crews plan to change tactics due to
climate change speaking with a Daily
Mail executive producer art Dekker
Watson jr. said that the rise in water
temperatures has forced some of the
boats to strike out for new territory
that is more dangerous because of fierce
storms and is further from rescue
workers if something goes wrong though
Watson omits the show is careful to
avoid the political controversy
surrounding climate change he does admit
that both the production staff and the
crabbing crews have a personal stake and
how the changing environment affects the
fishing industry as a whole
when something like this comes up it's
felt by all of them I love making this
show and so does the rest of my team
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to